there's in the parentheses that's going
to go in for X on the right side of the
equation so for example if you wanted to
find out what is f of three you would
simply put three in place of X and
simplify so this would be six minus
three which equals three now sometimes
there may be more than one quantity that
has X in it you would just replace that
X with whatever the input is here if it
was a you would put in a if it was seven
you would put in seven okay but the way
composition of functions work is instead
of doing one step and then another step
and then another step what you can do is
you can do it all in one step you can
compose the functions for example like
this f of G of X so here what you can
see is G of X is our input okay and what
we're going to do is let's say we wanted
to find out F of G of two just give you
a simple example so what you would do is
you would go to the G function you'd put
two in place of X so I'd be two squared
is four plus one more is five so this
whole quantity here is five now now
you're going to put five into your F
functions so you're gonna put five in
place of X that's two times five is 10
minus 3 is 7 so this whole quantity
equals seven ok so what we had to do is
we had to first go to our G function get
an answer then put it into our F
function get an answer but we can do
this process all in one step and I'll
show you how that works so we're gonna
just calculate what f of G of X is okay
so G of X is x squared plus one so I'm
gonna substitute that in for G of X okay
like so alright with me so far so then
what we're gonna do is we're going to
put this quantity into our F function so
remember whatever is in parentheses goes
in place for X on the right side of the
equation so this is going to be equals
to x this is our input x squared plus 1
minus 3 so that comes out to 2x squared
plus 2 minus 3 which is 2x squared
- one okay so this is what f of G of x
equals two x squared minus one if we
were to go back to this previous example
where we found out F of G of two well we
can do now is we can put 2 in for X 2
squared is 4 times 2 is 8 minus 1 is 7
see we have an expression now here that
can do both of these operations all at
once without having to do go to the G
function find an answer then put that
into the F function get an answer here
we have something that can do that
operation all in one one step okay you
just have to substitute in 2x and you're
going to get the composition of these
two functions together now not to be
confused here if we were to write this
as G of f of X this is a completely
different ok operation here we're
putting the F function into the G
function the way this would look is 2x
minus 3 that's this quantity here that's
our input for our G function so that's
going to be we're putting this in place
of X so that's going to be 2x minus 3
the quantity squared because we're
squaring it our input plus 1 if we
simplify we get 4x squared minus 12x
plus 9 plus one more which is plus 10 so
here's F of this is G of f of X but you
can see is not the same as f of G of X
okay so the order is important which one
you're putting in first and which one
second
so here's a couple examples f of X G of
X composing the functions I'm going to
show you one last example here we've got
another function H of X but I'm going to
show you another notation that some
books use and that's this notation right
here see you had H of F okay so you see
this notation here this is the same
thing as H of f of X I prefer this
notation because it looks like this is
the inner parentheses in your work
from the inside out like following your
order of operations here it actually
appears as if you're working from the
right to the left which is a little bit
counterintuitive for some students
because we're used to reading from left
to right but what you're actually doing
is you're working from the inside out so
to find the set H of F of X f of X is 2x
minus 3 2x minus 3 now we're putting
that into our H function okay so for
whatever's in parentheses here that's
our input that's going in for X on the
right side so this is going to equal 3
divided by 2x minus 3 minus 4 and you
can simplify that down a little bit
further that's going to be 3 divided by
2x minus 7 and so there you go that's a
composition of functions one thing you
want to notice here is that X cannot
equal 7 halves because then you'd be
dividing by zero so that's the
restriction on the domain something you
want to watch out for but go ahead and
review this video composition of
functions if you have a value you can
just go ahead and do it in multiple
steps but if you want to just find like
a generic formula for the composition of
the two functions these are the stuffs
that you're going to want to go through
so I'll see you in the next video